[Musique]
une sonnerie qui restera sans réponse
à reims les livreurs des plateformes
hubrid ces délits verrous sont en grève
et ne prennent plus les commandes des
clients
ils estiment que leurs courses sont sous
payés tous travaillent sous le statut
d'auto entrepreneur et se voit donc
contraint de payer 22 % de charges
sociales des revenus amputés de presque
un quart de leur montant dans de telles
conditions difficiles pour eux de
joindre les deux bouts
aujourd'hui tout le monde du son grève
par rapport à la base de deux t'arrive
en maintenant on reçoit des commandes à
75 centimes à 95 centimes vous savez pas
pourquoi
plus on est dans des restaurants plus on
est sensé de payer je vais rien dire et
maintenant le problème c'est que les
prix baissent entre l'éleveur restaurant
avant sur chaque commande minimum
c'était 4 50 donc n'importe quelle
distance que tu faisais c'était 4 5 ans
maintenant il n'y a plus du tout 2
minimum le minimum maintenance et
envahir 210 en moyenne une course est
rémunéré entre 4 euros et 4 euros 50
certains livreurs dénonce des courses
payés en dessous d'un euro
les grévistes attendent des
restaurateurs une forme de solidarité
qui passerait notamment par un boycott
des célèbres plate forme pendant
quelques temps des restaurants impactés
par ce mouvement de grève
en plus de la crise du coc vite 19 une
double peine pour les professionnels du
secteur
alors nous on est prêts fortement touché
et est concerné indirectement par cette
grève
c'est le troisième jour de grève déjà
pour nous les trois fois le regroupement
se fait devant notre restaurant donc on
voit très bien ce qui se passe on
soutient totalement les les grévistes et
les livreurs parce que on comprend leur
leur message et le pacte soit difficile
pour eux on est un peu déçu d'être le
dommage collatéral de cette petite
bataille entre les plateformes et les
livreurs on sent très peu de soutien de
la part des déplacements parce qu'on
envoie des messages mais on n'a pas de
retour d un droit de grève on peut rien
dire on peut rien y faire
de son côté s'ils délivrent ou s'est
défendu dans un communiqué en assurant
qu aucune course n'est payé moins de 1
euro
la célèbre plateforme de livraison
condamne ce mouvement de grève qu'elle
estime inutile au vu du contexte global
lié à la crise sanitaire